we rolling over here guys rolling
I love truth or dare I love would you
rather I love to truce and lie
oh okay that's easy for answer oh oh is
it there's that than the way the game is
played superfast
well that's how we used to play it okay
girls laning sweet let's do it
yeah arrow flash because we can talk to
tech flash arrow he's got muscles
I think flash sweep me off my feet no
comment
Batman Batman hun percent that month for
sure sorry Brandon sorry Brandon yeah
sorry bro he's much more cleanly that's
true I guess after a while like I should
have got my Superman think of all the
gadgets that you'll have just laying her
out
[Music]
that's one I love warmer I still like
the coal didn't know nope
I think mom my family would appreciate
it he would I I don't know I love them
both
diplomatic I'd say heat wave I think
he's so charming secretly under that
yeah he's a big cuddly bear Captain Cold
neither that sounds like a terrible idea
I can't I can't honor that question
[Music]
dev stroke is kilobots away two colas
she's bringing the Highland to Richard I
do not like that killer frost I would go
with killer frost as well because I feel
like I could maybe still talk some sense
into Kaitlyn killer frost killer frost I
could convince her out of her state like
whatever he look Frost
danielle Panabaker she's like mama bear
she would take care of me
oh oh that's thinking ahead I like that
invisibility huh yes invisibility cousin
Sarkozy invisibility would be fun to see
what everybody is saying about you
are they really telling the truth about
you how they feel about you I just so
dangerous
Joker Joker Heath Ledger yes these
legends are good or Jim Carrey Riddler
you pick neither that sounds like a lot
of work
yeah I'd rather like HBO now with the
penguin yeah
[Applause]
[Music]